hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game where we're covering the
first encounter of uh yaniponishi and
the magnus carlsen so the world champion
ended the world champs championship
challenger for 2021
that will happen in november in dubai uh
and
this comes as a suggestion from rukel
shukla it's a game we haven't covered
yet and it's uh it's quite a nice one
and
even though uh this is not uh exactly
how they looked like in 2002 they were
a little bit uh they were not 12 yet
they were 11
something uh this is what they actually
looked like but i couldn't find um
a nice enough photo to use as a as a
profile image for them
uh you know for the the two little
photos on the left of the board
uh but this is how they actually looked
this is a magnus and nipple
uh the two gentlemen on the on the far
right uh
there you can see uh on the first uh
from the right is nipple then it's
magnus
uh that's uh approximately uh what they
looked like at
that time and that's a david howell the
tall dude in the middle
and i believe next to him is dmitry
andreikin and
i do not know the two
on the left uh but yeah uh this is what
they actually look like but
those uh if i use that as a profile
photo it'd be very very low quality so
that's why i'm showing this to you
uh and that's why i'm using these ones i
i thought
maybe i'd use uh ones where they're
grown up but i i decided against it so
uh basically uh this is what you see but
imagine that
while you're watching the game so uh
like i said the under 12 european
championship played in peninsula spain
and this is a game from round five a
very nice one so let's see what happened
in their first encounter and whether
they even imagined that uh
that one day uh this like i said it was
uh
almost 20 years ago uh would be a
precursor to the world chase
championship match
so nipple with the white pieces opens
with e4
magnus goes for knight to f6 he goes for
the aliyah's defense we have
e5 attacking that knight knight to d5
and now
knight to f3 we have d6 immediately
challenging this
pawn on e5 and now d4 nipple defends it
we have captures on e5
and now knight captures on e5 so the
last larson variation of the aliens
defense
we have g6 magnus prepares to fiance to
the dark square bishop and now
bishop to c4 attacking the knight
and usually in some lines this knight
will come to b6 to kick away the bishop
but here of course it'd be a terrible
mistake as you'd get
checkmated like this so instead a magnus
defends it with c6
we have knight to c3 again the knight
cannot move and now
bishop to e6 for the moment uh blocking
the development of your e6 pawn
but the magnus has everything taken care
of as you'll see in the game so here at
nipple castles
and here there are a few games where
bishop the g7 was played but
as of knights to d7 we have a position
that has
never been reached again uh uh since
2002
uh so here at knight to d7 we have queen
to f3 nepo going
very aggressive with his development and
the bishop to g7 now by magnus
all right the knight is now attacked
twice so we need to defend it so rook to
e1 by nipple
uh and magnus castles now and queen to
g3
all right so here you can now start
advancing your f pawn maybe to
add more more protection to the center
but here magnus just goes on a capture
fest and he completely simplifies the
position
he plays knight captures on e5 d
captures with
knight cap president c3 queen captures
uh and uh sorry queen captures on c3
and now bishop captures on c4 so trading
uh three of the minor pieces in the
center and immediately queen to d5 going
after this
queen trade and now asking what do you
want to do so if
if nipple trades here which is
definitely possible then captures
captures magnets will play e6 and it's a
uh you know pretty much a drawn
game not much to be done about this it's
even black who has the same
open c file so you can maybe even nicely
double up here on the c
file uh but still it's very unlikely
that either players would be able to do
anything here so instead after queen to
d5 we have queen back to e2
and nipple wants to keep the queens on
the board and now rook a to d8
magnus grabs hold of the d file uh so
you don't have any
rook to d1 ideas in the future or maybe
even developing the bishop in rook 31
so here bishop to g5 attacking the e7
pawn
and now while magnus could defend it uh
with the rook for example he decides to
do it with
queen to e6 so
that rook a to d1 does not come with an
attack on the queen and the queen is
very very
very much safe here so here we have
queen to e3 now
if you go over aggressive with f4 then
magnus says some
h6 resources and after bishop h4 maybe
queen to d4
and it's uh well it's a very tricky
position then the f4 pawn is under
attack then rook after
d8 is coming and black does get some uh
initiative going on
so instead after queen to e6 we have
queen to e3 by nipple
uh now uh not only defending the bishop
preparing bishop to h6 maybe to trade
off this guy here but also just
uh plainly attacking the a7 pawn so here
magnus defends at b6 and now
a4 nipple wants to play a5 and the bust
open uh the the queen side here
we've looked at the five magnus
defending the f5 square and now
bishop to f4 so what do you play here
uh magnus goes queen to f5 improves the
activity of the queen
he has uh e6 ready rook after d8 is
ready queen is attacking the c2 pawn all
of this is ready
so nipple now offers a queen trade with
queen to e4 but now it's magnus who
declines the queen trade
and he simply uh keeps his control of
the d file
now queen to d7 so rook is not coming to
d1
anytime soon and now c3
so uh what do you play here uh magnus
just uh brings another rook into the
game so rook after d8 now we have this
nice
rook queen rook sandwich on the d file
we have h3
uh some breeding room for the king and
now comes queen to e6 still you could
play e6
uh but magnus is still reluctant to push
this pawn for the moment he's keeping it
there and now there's a triple attack on
this e5
pawn so here queen to e2 now he says
okay i might be interested in
infiltrating with queen to a6 going
after your uh queen side pawns so here
uh magnus just defends against it so
rook to d3
and now a5 finally nipple gets that
pawn to a5 with b5 magnus blocks this
and now even a6 so grabbing a lot of
space here on the queen side
uh magnus says all right i'm gonna do
the same he pushes c5 and now
you will have ideas in the future maybe
b for maybe just c4 cementing that rook
on d3
so queen to e4 by magnus uh now again
with some ideas of maybe queen to b7
going after the a7 pawn and the b5 pawn
and here magnus just goes queen to d5
and
offers a queen trade and it's only now
that nipple accepts
uh this queen trade so queen captures
through captures on d5
and now rook to a5 going after this b5
pawn so we have an end game here
two rooks against two rooks and a bishop
pair each
uh the b5 pawn is under attack so c4
defends the pawn
uh and now king to f1 nipple starts
bringing the king
into the game finally e6 by magnus uh
and now bishop back to e3 goes after the
a7 pawn
so uh magnus defends it we have rook 8
to d7
and now bishop to d4 and if you look at
the position now
it doesn't really appear that uh
something can be done here this is a
monster chain here it's very unlikely
that you will be able to break this
uh the f6 square is supported twice by
the pawn and by the bishop there's
really not much you can do here so here
uh
magnus played bishop to f8 he may be
thinking about something like bishop to
c5 maybe to add another attacker to the
d4 square
but now nepo has a very very interesting
idea
and uh often when you have to look for
such ideas you have to look for
breakthroughs
and what kind of breakthroughs are the
here in the position well obviously
there aren't any breakthroughs on the
kings side you can't really push this
the f5 square is defended
twice you can't really push this point
if you push this point you can trade it
but that's pretty much it
so one thing you could consider is b3
and this is exactly what nipple does
first he plays rook to b1
and now b3 is coming and now magnus
could have
just uh continued with his plan of
bishop to c5
and this probably is the way to go it
includes a temporary pawn sacrifice here
but it doesn't really matter bishop
captures
and now after for example captures
captures and captures we're gonna
capture on d4
and now we have this end game that's
pretty much uh
pretty much will be a draw if played
correctly uh but okay after rook to b1
we have bishop to e7 by magnus and now
nepo uses this to of course a
breakthrough on the queen side he plays
b3
uh we have bishop to d8 now attacking
the rook here
rook to a2 and now rook captures on d4
this was carlson's idea uh not
interested in the draw he's going for a
win with the black pieces so here
c captures and now c3 creating a
a very very strong pass pawn here that
will probably
uh well it will probably be possible to
escort
the pawn you could capture here maybe
you could play rook here
maybe you can bring the bishop to g5 to
guard the the queening square so there
are
some very interesting possibilities here
but one thing nipple doesn't want to
allow is magnus to play b4 here so he
plays b
for uh uh instead of magnus a very rare
occasion where b4 is actually good for
both players so here uh we have
bishop the g5 if magnus goes for the d
for pawn
i know uh you guys are watching what
happens if he just grabs the pawn
and then we go after this pawn for
example rook c2 and
once this pawn is defended and there
really aren't all that many great
squares for you to defend it from
uh let's say you go here then just king
to e2 and you have to
move the rook and if you go for
something like rook to c4
then rook to b3 and we're still gonna
pick up this pawn there's really nothing
you can do about this
so instead after b4 we have bishop to g5
by magnus now
just guarding the queening square and
now comes to rook to d1
nepal defends this spawn we have rook to
c7 preparing to push the pawn
and of course uh nipple cannot allow the
spawn force so rook to c2
and now magnus goes for bishop to e7
goes
after this b4 pawn uh but now the
position is uh completely
winning for nepo so uh feel free to
pause the video here and
win this game for nepo and win the first
game
the two of them have ever played well
i'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
not doing anything weird like i don't
know rook to a1
uh and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course
d5 i know you guys were looking at b4
but there's already a pawn on b4 so you
had to look for something else but
in in this game it's actually d5 and d5
is an incredibly strong move because if
you don't do anything
then d6 is coming so you have to do
something uh problem is
if you capture here uh it doesn't really
help you just root captures and now this
pawn is under attack and then rook b7
comes and then your
entire position just falls apart for
example bishop captures on b4 we're
going to capture on b5 attack the bishop
and once the bishop moves doesn't really
matter where rook to b7 of course we
have to
decline the trade if we trade this is
just game over the pawn promotes the
queen
so we'd have to move it let's say rook
here and then we're just going to
capture the spawn move the rook and then
we have a nice
pass past a pawn and with being up so
much material this is a completely
winning game for
uh for white so instead after this d5
move
uh magnus tried bishop cactus on b4 but
now nepo just pushes d6 and now he has a
monster passed pawn here uh we have rook
to c8 and here uh
we have rook to b1 by nippo and it was
in this position on mu 41
that magnus carlsen resigned the game
and their first ever game
uh that the two of them have ever played
in the uh european uh
a youth championship of 2002 goes to ian
nippon issue so here
you resign because the bishop is under
attack if the bishop moves you lose the
b5 pawn and that's pretty much it if you
go to c5 then we can even grab this pawn
because now
there is not much you can do here and
other than that
you really have no moves if you play
this then you lose this pawn again
we we can we're going to go to b7 if you
play bishop to b6 we can even play
rook captures and b6 even this is
possible for example upon captures we're
going to play a7
and now uh at any point uh
this is simply unplayable we're
threatening rook captures here
if you capture we're going to bring a
queen into the game and anything other
than that simply doesn't work if kink
the g7 we're just gonna play d7
and this is uh impossible to hold
whatever you do
rook captures is coming and then we're
gonna we're we're gonna start promoting
some queens
yeah magnus of course knew this after
rook to b1
uh he resigned and uh uh what a what a
great victory for yanipanic even though
uh magnus did have
uh a lot of ways to draw this game
but he decided to sacrifice the exchange
and
go for for a full victory uh which uh
cost him
in the end uh because he did not win the
uh
european under 12 championship uh but
neither did nepo
uh the winner of this uh uh under 12
european uh championship was actually
dmitry and draken
uh nipple got second place and magnus
got fourth
uh so yeah very very interesting stuff
and so you guys don't forget uh this is
them at
this age so uh when when whenever when
they were playing this game this is uh
who they were so you know in case you
you've seen some very very strong moves
in case you were imagining you know all
the magnus and old nepal nope
these two gentlemen uh played played
those moves
yeah that's very very scary i know uh
but yeah
uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it thank you for recommending
such a
nice game uh always use hashtag
suggestions so i can spot your
suggestions
easier uh we're gonna keep uh finding
nice games between magnus and nipple up
until
the world's your championship match
while we cover everything else that's
happening
in the chess world uh so yeah uh once
again i would like to thank austin
delerio justin brockhouse
frederic krusek akram the pilot and kd
nuggets for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day